How often should I run standard labs?
Well, that's another, it depends answer to this.
So it depends on if your standard labs
have been running normal
and you're not doing anything different
as things that would cause abnormalities.
Let's say you're not taking medication,
that could cause issues with your liver markers,
you're not taking fed medicine,
then you can spread those out.
So it's all depends on,
hey, my last labs were normal.
Well, when were the ones before that?
Two months were those normal?
Those were a little bit off.
Okay, let's maybe go three months on these.
Or my last labs were abnormal.
You had me run them again this month.
And now they're still abnormal.
We're gonna still keep running them on a monthly basis.
So it depends on what we're looking at,
what we're dealing with.
But in general, how often should anybody run labs
if they were consistently normal?
Well, if you have a major change of symptoms,
you should investigate why you have that change of symptoms.
But otherwise, I don't think it's wrong
for a healthy person with no diagnosis to wait a year
to run labs to make sure everything is normal.
That makes sense.
You're just trying to use some reasonableness
in your investigations.